[Music]
is briefing his soldiers on their
mission
they will escort civilians to banibango
a town near the jazz border with mali
a delicate mission armed groups have
attacked the town many times in the last
few years
at the command center lieutenant colonel
sami nomani and his team analyze the
latest intelligence from the region
samino shows me the 330 kilometer long
border area where the islamic state in
the greater sahara is active the
icy-linked armed group is seen as the
biggest security threat in the region
its leader abul walida saharawi was
killed in a drone strike in august last
year
general muhammad tumba and the 2000
soldiers under his command have been in
the battlefield for years but the fight
is far from over
difficulty
the biggest challenge we're facing is
that there is no malian or burkinabe
army on the other side of the border so
we can talk and plan attacks for the
last five years the malian army
retreated from the area and we're acting
on our own
outgunned the army relies heavily on
intelligence from foreign troops
this has become a forward base for
nigeria's army fighting against iceland
al-qaeda affiliates in the sahaja region
they're backed by american and european
special forces but a few kilometers
north towards the border with mali
armed groups are expanding they continue
to control a vast
territory now they are threatening to
take the fight south towards guinea
ivory coast and senegal
for years niger mali and pokina faso
have been trying to stop a rise in
attacks by armed groups
here in this camp the displaced have
been waiting for security to improve in
the border area but many traumatized by
the conflict
are afraid to return
i was looking after my sheep when
fighters on motorbikes stopped me they
saw a pen in my pocket and thought i was
an informant they blindfolded me and
beat me i lost my sheep and ever since
i've been here in this camp
for the time being the army remains on
alert after suffering major setbacks in
the last few years armed groups are now
forging new alliances finding new
recruits and hoping to establish a state
of their own across west africa and the
sahel
al-jazeera the town of wallam in
southwest niger